it's intimidating to walk behind him it
is or in front of it's just intimidating
good god jonathan let me ask you because
we chatted
once before
look at the way he's looking at me
ladies and gentlemen
this man has a face that says do not
mess with me
when in your life did you realize you
had
this incredible face the first time i
ever got hit in the mouth right really
really i would i could look like mother
teresa and i would walk in some place
and somebody would say who do you think
you are and they would strike me
so you had this face and that glare when
you were like an 11 year old boy with a
lollipop is that what you're saying i
think it took place more like four or
five at four or five
you were a baby in a crib saying gaga
bob i have to ask you you were cast in
season two yes and i
learned very recently that when you were
cast you had never seen the show
uh did anyone in the cast catch on oh
really oh
this guy was wise to it
when i was you tried to keep it you
tried to
deal i had little kids at home so i
couldn't put the show on i got little
kids
[Laughter]
i want the government to hear that yeah
okay so obama will get you
right no no right obama the president
the president will not get you
i don't know what's going on here but i
can't wait to find out i'm trying to get
him a right-wing talk show
so how did they rise up to you bob how
did they wise this guy i would say the
name wrong or with the wrong emphasis
and then he'd go
you don't watch the show do you
but look here's the deal i watched it i
knew what the tone was i just lit i just
played saul goodman i was just saw
goodman that's all i knew i got i wanted
what he wanted
and that was it
and uh and then when my kids got old
enough and
took a hike and went to summer camp oh i
thought they went to the circus or
something
once i sold my children i was able to
watch the show
uh and i watched jonathan you've been
known to argue with the writers over
grammar you it was important to you
that your characters speak uh with
correct grammar is that right i thought
mike should help them with the big words
yes
i did so
give us an example of a fight you had
with them um
who who killed who
well
who killed who killed whom but then i
believe it's an object preposition if
they're
right uh
[Applause]
and and schnoz refused schneiz wouldn't
turn it i said who's not sure
help us out here who's the rider oh he
was the writer of the episode wouldn't
change it wouldn't change i said tom
don't dumb mike down just
correct it yeah he wouldn't do it
whom didn't
[Applause]